Buah! La volta al món a peu, dia 238. Buah! He dormit fatal avui, però fatal, fatal, eh?
Bueno, més que res, a les 5 m'he despertat i ja no puc tornar a dormir més. Llavors, coses que passen, no?
Després a les 7, que era l'hora de llevar-se, m'he tornat a dormir. Llavors són les 8.40 ara, que és bastant tard,
i et dóna el sol que flipes.
Bueno, mireu on estic, eh? Quina vall més maca, més maca, més maca. Va, et recullo i us explico què faig aquí.
Avui és dissabte 25 de juliol i ahir vaig caminar 30 quilòmetres, aquí els teniu, però no vaig gravar vídeo.
Vaig fer descans, també teniu per aquí les estadístiques, i bueno, va ser un dia que vaig començar molt tard.
Vaig sortir de la gascauza aquella, que per cert va ploure tota la nit. Sort que estava ja dintre.
Vaig fer uns 30 quilòmetres i uns, no sé si 800 de desnivell positiu.
No està molt bé.
Molt maco, Borjomi, us deixo algunes fotos.
Pobre bastant turístic, amb, bueno, molts visitants, tot molt maco, fons d'aigua mineral.
I després vaig sortir de Borjomi i vaig caminar per una zona així, com aquesta pista, amb una vall, buscosa,
fins a acabar una espècie de congost bastant estret.
Vaig sortir del congost i vaig acampar aquí, on heu vist avui.
Ui.
Ara la pujada és forta i costa parlar, eh, mentre camino.
Bueno, part d'ahir i part d'avui seguirem la Transcaucàsica.
Sí, hi ha dues Transcaucàsiques.
La del nord de Georgia, la que vaig fer jo, que va pel Gran Càucas, hi pots veure glaceres, muntanyes de 5.000 metres, etc.
I la Transcaucàsica 2, que travessa tot el país d'Armènia.
Doncs han connectat les dues Transcaucàsiques, i tu pots fer-la de dalt i connectar amb la Transcaucàsica d'Armènia.
I ara estem aquí, a aquesta connexió a la Transcaucàsica.
Em portarà avui per aquesta pista, envoltada de prats alpins i boscos genials i muntanyes.
I com podeu veure, toca vent i toca muntanya per començar.
Hem de superar un port que està als 1.000 i escaig metres, 1.885 per ser més exacte,
2 quilòmetres i 300 metres de desneig positiu.
No n'hi ha per tant.
Let's go!
1.6 quilòmetres i 200 metres de desneig positiu fins al coi.
Molt de vent, però unes vistes increïbles.
Crec que les millors vistes del que portem de volta al món a peu, eh?
Et diria?
Ua, brutal, brutal.
Vam fer zona molt alpina l'altra vegada que vaig estar a joves.
ja, o sigui, fa unes
setmanes, però clar, com que
estava núvol no es veia res. Aquí es veu
l'estació d'esquí, per exemple. Aquí a
Borjomi hi ha una estació d'esquí i, bueno, és
a l'altra banda, d'acord? Però es veu la part
de dalt, suposo que ja són els telecadires
o, bueno, alguna antena, el que sigui.
Súper,
súper, súper maco.
La Transcaucàsica, per això, tela, eh? Aquí no,
però hi ha llocs que he d'avançar per
herbes així d'altes.
Un clàssic de la Transcaucàsica.
Estic parant bastant, eh?
Em costa caminar pel matí.
Jo soc més de tardes.
Mireu, allà hi ha un campament
de pastors i hi ha unes vaques.
Crec que això encara
no és el coi. És una mica
més enrere.
Buah! Tinc el vent
de cara, eh? És fotut!
Allà tenim la cabana del pastor
o com li vulguis dir.
Hi ha gent, perquè veig fum
i veig un cotxe.
No veig ovelles, cosa que
em tranquil·litza respecte
si hi ha un gos.
Ostres, tu, quin vent!
Així us tinc a contrallunc, però com a mínim el micròfon
no li dóna el vent.
Per no jugar-me-la,
no aniré seguint la ruta
i a la cabana del pastor, sinó que
retiraré una mica per aquí
i no passaré pel costat.
I així potser no
no tinc trobada
amb un possible gos.
Sóc paranoic?
Bueno, és el
és el punt més delicat
de Georgia
en quant a gos pastor,
perquè és el punt més alt
i jo he vist com se les gasten
aquests gossos i no juguem, eh?
No juguem.
Vale!
Calma, calma i tranquil·litat.
Ha aparegut el gos des d'allà, cosa que no m'esperava.
I hi ha molts gossos, sí, però han aparegut, ha aparegut el pastor, no sé què m'està dient.
Han aparegut els pastors que estaven dintre la cabana i no els havia vist i ara ja han sortit, llavors ja està, calmats, tothom tranquil.
Veus com les meves sospites eren, eren fundades?
Gammars jove!
Gammars jove.
Ja, ja, ja, ok.
Ja, ja, no, no problem.
No sé què m'està dient.
No sé què m'ha dit, però ha fet el gest de mossegar
i el gest de no.
No sé, he entès com que
hauria d'anar amb compte, no ho sé, no ho sé.
Aquí no ensenya el micròfon i el que comento és que sí, sí hi havia ovelles, el que passa és que no les havia vist.
N'hi havia moltíssimes, jo compto unes tres-centes.
A més a més, estava com mig desviat de la ruta i estava anant en direcció a la cabana d'un dels pastors que s'enfada en mi,
que els gossos que té s'estaven posant molt nerviosos
i em comença a assenyalar cap a dalt dient
tira cap allà, tira cap allà, home.
i jo, vale, vale, vale.
Vale, no he pogut activar el micròfon en aquesta última trobada.
M'han sortit els gossos de l'home aquest
i l'home no els criava, no els criava, jo, tio.
Tio.
I diu el tio, sí, sí,
tu segueix caminant que ja,
ja, ja se n'aniran, jo, tio.
Ajuda'm una mica, al final els ha criat i se n'ha anat.
Bueno,
llarg això, eh, però
ho documento tot perquè espero que sigui
l'última trobada d'aquest estil
de tots a la volta amb una peu.
Bueno,
tampoc hi ficaria la mà al foc, eh,
però podria ser que sí.
Les males notícies no s'acaben.
A punt d'arribar al port
me'n dono compte que el receptor del micròfon
me'n dono compte que el receptor del micròfon no hi és.
El micròfon que faig servir
es composa de l'emissor, que és això
que porto al coll, i el receptor que sempre
porto a la butxaca i el vaig enganxant i desenganxant
del mòbil quan vaig a gravar.
Doncs en algun moment s'ha caigut
i no el sé trobar. Una desgràcia.
M'hi estic una bona estona,
tipo 20 minuts, inclús torno enrere,
però res. És clar, amb
tota aquesta herba és com buscar
una agulla en un paller.
Fa ràbia perquè els micròfons eren nous,
me'ls van portar a Cotaisi
i em van costar 90 euros. Molta ràbia.
Decideixo tirar cap al coll igualment
i ve un dels pastors
amb un cavall i els gossos
simplement borden una mica però estan
tranquils perquè està el pastor al costat.
Encara bastant trist
pel que ha passat. No és un ritm molt
quan el pastor baixa i em diu
no sé què. No ho entenc
i resulta que volia oferir-me un
cigarro. I jo no, no. Gràcies, gràcies.
Sensacions molt
agradolces al coronar
el coll. Penso
en el micròfon i també penso
en el que pot venir
perquè segueixen les muntanyes,
seguim a més de 2.000 metres
i poden haver-hi més ovelles.
I ja de seguida les veig, totes aquelles
d'allà són ovelles. La diferència
és que aquesta vegada m'aproparia
teòricament primer a les ovelles i després
al campament, cosa que no m'interessa.
He de fer el contrari perquè em vegin
els pastors. Com l'espai és bastant
obert i crec que es pot caminar
bastant bé, decideixo mantenir
una gran, gran, gran distància de seguretat
a les ovelles perquè no em passi res
i bona decisió perquè
no se m'apropa cap gos.
Les 12 del migdia només porto 7,75 km
caminats però
gairebé 1.000 metres de desnivell positiu.
Primer grup
d'ovelles controlat.
L'he passat i no ha passat res.
Ara el segon. Doncs
també segueixo caminant cap a l'esquerra
per no creuar-me'l
i he de fer una mica de volta
comporta una mica bastant de volta
però bueno, tu, ja està.
Si s'ha de fer, es fa.
El vent aquí i avui
és brutal. Miro l'aplicació
MeteoBlue i diu que hi ha
50-60 km per hora.
Aquest cotxe
és bona senyal. Vol dir
que hi ha camí
i que podré arribar
a algun lloc. Això sí,
toca creuar aquest riu.
A veure, com sempre dic
em podria mullar les sabates però sempre
que pugui evitar-ho, millor, no?
Sembla que per allà
podria ser possible si faig
algun saltironet. Anem a provar-ho.
Ok.
Primera aconseguida.
Segon salt més delicat.
Ok.
Aconseguit.
Deixo estar els prats
i els camins estranys
i arribo a una pista.
Cosa que és una gran alegria.
I després aquest llac, tu.
Amb unes vaques.
Ai, les vaques.
No passa res.
Després apareix el pagès
sobre un cavall. Però mireu, eh?
Mireu que espectacular.
M'agrada.
És espectacular aquest llac
amb totes aquestes muntanyes.
Tot verd.
Gairebé res de bosc.
Sense paraules.
A veure, el mapa diu que en aquest petit poble
hi ha una benzinera.
A veure si hi ha un supermercat.
Així a priori sembla molt petita, eh?
Efectivament, no hi ha marquet ni res.
Però, però,
el que m'interessava a mi era això.
Un andoi.
Anem a comprovar a veure si funciona.
Funciona!
Estupendo.
Doncs res, em quedo aquí a dinar una mica
i a baixar les tensions.
Mentre dino intento buscar
a veure si trobo el mateix micròfon que he perdut
a Tbilisi. A veure si el puc comprar
aquí a Georgia. L'altra vegada
l'havia estat buscant
i no l'havia trobat, per això vaig fer que me'l portessin.
He provat de parlar amb una botiga
per WhatsApp, a veure si tenien
el model, perquè tenien
altres de la mateixa marca, però just aquest no.
I em contesten que sí.
Que el tenen en estoc a la botiga.
I això em treu un gran pes de sobre.
Seguiré havent d'apagar el micròfon,
cosa que em fastigueix una mica,
però eh, com a mínim tindrà solució.
Segueixo flipant
amb el paisatge. Jo crec que mai havia estat
a un lloc així.
Els camps i aquestes muntanyes tan obertes
sense tenir cap pic proper.
Però atenció, perquè el dia s'anava
a esgarrar de manera tràgica
i sobtada. Un altre
campament amb animals i gossos.
Tinc la immensa
sort que aquest vehicle,
no sé com definir-lo, que no és dels
pastors, s'apropa a mi
a la mateixa altura que estic jo
del campament aquest. I per tant
no em quedo a soles amb els gossos.
Immensa sort. Els he dit
què faig? Perquè clar, ells anaven
en sentit contrari. No parlaven anglès,
però em fan entendre que no segueixi,
em fan el símbol
de mort, ja sabeu, amb el polze
passant-se'l d'una banda a l'altra
del coi. Mentre ells estan aquí,
els gossos que ens rodegen no s'apropen.
Què passa llavors?
Doncs immensa sort de que
venen dos altres vehicles
i els demanen que em portin
fins on van ells, fins a la propera vila.
I sí, sí, sí,
malauradament he d'agafar el meu
primer cotxe de la volta al món a peu
per saltar-me un tros de la ruta.
No m'agrada,
estic trist havent de fer això,
perquè fins ara havia fet
tots i cada un dels quilòmetres a peu,
però crec que podia haver sigut
una qüestió de vida o mort.
És que no només era aquell campament,
n'hi havia d'altres, m'havien dit.
És que, després d'aquest n'hi ha un altre,
després n'hi ha un altre, després n'hi ha un altre.
I sí, sí, anant amb cotxe ja anàvem veient
ovelles, de vaques
i tal. Els que em porten
crec que venien d'una vila propera
a fer excursions a turistes
amb cavall, i un cop
a la setmana tornaven al seu poble
o on tinguessin el campament.
Aquest home d'aquí, que veieu penjat del camió,
és el que em cedeix el seu seient.
Els dos vehicles estaven plens
i el tio surt del cotxe i et diu
tu senta't aquí, i se'n va
al camió. Eh,
on haia gent del tio.
Quan m'han fet avançar? Doncs no gaire,
la veritat, per sort. Aquí
al mapa podeu veure la meva ruta original
i on m'han deixat, que és el punt
blau. I aquí fent una mica de zoom.
Ells en total em porten
17 quilòmetres, com podeu
veure en el mapa aquest. Però
com m'han fet desviar, al final
potser m'han fet guanyar uns
5 o 10, no ho sé.
Això sí, hem estat uns 45
quilòmetres conduint, eh, només per 17 quilòmetres.
Perquè clar, és que
el terreny ni tan sols era pista forestal.
Era un track,
de muntanya.
Havien d'anar posant el reductor, anaven super lent.
Mireu aquest creuament de riu.
Una cosa és creuar
un petit
riarol, però això...
No sé a quina altura arribava,
però potser tenia això, no sé,
mig metre o més, eh,
de profunditat. Em conviden
a quedar-me amb ells aquesta nit
i malauradament els he de dir
que no, perquè he de seguir caminant.
I em deixen al primer poble que hi ha,
on, inesperadament,
hi ha un market i puc comprar
poca cosa. Avui,
amb tantes emocions, sí que em venia de gust
algú de sucre,
però segueixo, segueixo amb el repte.
I agafo unes patates fregides, que tampoc
és el més saludable del món,
però avui necessitava aquesta satisfacció
i no hi havia puré de patates.
Em conviden a menjar alguna cosa,
així, improvisat, i després
ja m'acomiado. Podria haver anat
amb ells fins al següent poble, no sé fins on anaven,
però, no, no.
Jo els he preguntat, ei,
a partir d'aquí, és segur?
Hi ha ovelles? Hi ha gossos?
I em diuen, sí, sí, no hi ha ovelles,
no hi ha gossos, és segur, pots anar tranquil·lament.
Així que endavant,
la resta de la tarda ha sigut caminant
per aquests paisatges
no tan alpins, ja estem a una cota
inferior, però també molt macos.
Música
Hora de buscar lloc de campada.
Veig un lloc bastant interessant
a prop de la carretera.
Ho trobo, i sí, sí, són uns prats
amb visitant.
M'hi apropo a poc a poc,
a veure quan triguen a espantar-se.
Poc, trig a poc.
Joc fantàstic perquè el camp
ja està assegat, recollit,
tot.
A més, bastant verd, herba molt baixa.
Acampo i fem resum.
Bé, avui he de fer resum
aquí, ja a les fosques,
perquè he hagut de fer primer
la veu en off
i després fer el resum, perquè clar,
em repeteixo, no?
30... ostres, tu...
33 quilòmetres
i 1.500 metres de desnivell
positiu. Avui també ho he dividit
en dos tracs. Un
abans que em portessin en cotxe
i un després.
He parlat amb tres persones, les del
cotxe. Zero refrescs.
M'he gastat
un euro.
Posa-li dos, posa-li dos euros.
I cafès, cap.
Dia molt estrany,
molt estrany.
Per una part, el tema del micròfon,
que, bueno,
l'he pogut solucionar una mica,
però clar, el dia d'avui, doncs ha quedat
així raro, perquè el micròfon del mòbil
no s'escolta tan fort
i no s'escolta tan bé com el micròfon aquest.
També crec que està una mica espatllat. Llavors,
doncs, és clar,
no és l'ideal.
Però bueno, poder solucionar
a Tbilisi i, en segon
lloc, doncs una mica
trist
per haver hagut d'agafar el primer transport,
encara que hagi suposat poc
i encara que ho havia de fer, sí,
100%, ho havia de fer.
Però és com, bueno,
pervertir el repte.
No passa res, perquè, bueno,
si heu vist el vídeo del meu repte
a la meva ruta per Àsia, ja
sabeu que a Àsia no la recorreré completa.
Agafaré dos avions,
mínim. Per tant,
si jo ara m'he saltat un tros amb cotxe,
doncs tampoc hauria complert
el continent d'Àsia, igualment,
vull dir que no passa res.
Si això m'hagués passat a un altre continent,
el que hauria
de fer és, bueno, jo no puc tornar ja i continuar,
perquè estaria amb les mateixes dels gossos, no?
El que hauria de fer és borrar els dos
últims tracks,
quedar-me com que m'he quedat
a Bojorni i tornar amb algun
transport a Bojorni i continuar des de
Bojorni, seguir una altra ruta, per exemple,
per carretera fins a Tbilisi.
Però bueno, no ho faré perquè no cal.
Una pena, Georgia,
perquè és tan bonic, els paisatges
d'avui han sigut tan bonics
i no es poden gaudir caminant.
Perquè,
tens això, tens aquestes
manades
de gossos, perquè no sé
per què en tenen tant, sincerament,
agressius, que t'envolten
i que, bueno, és que...
El tio, quan ha dit el gesto aquest de matar,
m'ha fet així, eh?
Literalment m'ha fet així.
Com dient, si continues,
maten.
Heavy, heavy, heavy.
No sé si exageren o no,
m'ho crec, m'ho crec. Bueno,
doncs això, un dia raro,
però bueno, tu,
ja està. Dia...
El millor dia, passadísticament, potser,
ahir, ahir, amb catarapas.
Val, ja està, que el vídeo
ha quedat molt llarg, senyors.
Demà continuo, intento
gravar-ho amb el mòbil. Sí.
No? O què? Sí, intento
gravar amb el mòbil, no sé com quedarà.
Fer un vídeo més curt, suposo, perquè
no queda tan bé. No ho sé, però vull...
Vull fer com que arribo a
Tbilisi a peu, no? Com a mínim això, que ho veieu
en vídeo. Vinga, bona nit.